hello everyone and welcome to game 4 of
yesterday's match between Maxima Sheila
Graham and Magnus Carlsen uh sorry about
that let me just rewind it uh as you've
seen in the match so far Magnus won the
third game uh which means that now Maxim
has to win game four in order to force
tie break so game one game two ended in
a draw uh and uh Magnus only needs a
draw here with the black pieces and he
could play some sort of uh a boring
Berlin and and just force it run but no
he decides to go for the Sicilian
Defense again as we've had the Sicilian
Defense in or for all four games and um
sometimes the position is just so so fun
to play uh you don't want to draw you
actually want to win the position so
let's see what happened here we have
Pawn to E4 and pawn to see five magnets
again goes for the Sicilian Defense
Knight F3 E6 D4 the open Sicilian
captures captures and Knight to F6 with
Knight the C3 and Magnus Ops for the
taimano variation of the Sicilian with
Knight captures and C6 Knight D to B5 is
the most the popular still but Maxim
wants to mix it up as he has to play for
the win here B captures and now Pawn to
E5 Knight D5 and now at night the E4 so
all been seen before nothing new here
usually Bishop to B7 uh is not the move
you that is played here right away it is
Queen the C7 to stop the immediate
Knight to the D6 but this is exactly
what Magnus invites in he plays Bishop
to B7 and now Maxime does not shy away
from Knight to D6 check and of course
you have to capture this if you don't
you're just gonna
uh lose a material with pretty much
whatever white plays if you go King D7
like C4 even or just Knight captures on
B7 is fine so you have to capture it e
captures and now Pawn to C5 Magnus opens
up this diagonal uh we have Pawn to C4
and now Knight to B for immediately
challenging the Knight Pawn to A3 Knight
back to C6 and now Bishop to E3 so this
Pawn got all the way to D6 already uh
till move 10 uh so we'll see if Magnus
can do something about it we have Queen
to F6 putting pressure on the B2 pawn
queen to D2 defending and now uh Rook
the B8 getting ready to move the bishop
and to put even more pressure on that B2
pawn bishop captures and C5 and now
there is a game where Queen to E5 check
was played it was played between Ray
Robson and Bodie's girlfriend Boris
girlfriend played Queen to E5 check here
but he lost the game he was played
actually this year some three months ago
in the practice Festival but here Magnus
goes Bishop to B8 and Bishop to a 8 and
it is known as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game so now MBO has to
deal with the B2 Pawn hanging he plays
Bishop to B4 cuts off the rook and now
Queen to E5 with check with Bishop D2
and Knight captures on B4 with a
captures and Bishop captures on G2
attacking the rook and now well you
could play Rook to G1 Maxine first
throws in a rook to A5 it seems like a
very nice session took as it attacks the
queen but it's actually not the correct
move order the correct move order is
Rook to G1 because it's much stronger
now uh Magnus would not have the ability
to play Queen to E4 to just defend the
bishop here because Queen G5 and now the
bishop and the G7 Pawn are hanging which
seems like you could also do starting
with Rook day 5 but not really now
Magnus does have Rook a queen to E4 and
now after Rook to G1 he just plays
Bishop to F3 so much much uh Stronger
for black we have Rook captures and G7
Bishop captures an E2 and now Queen
captures an E2 Queen to B1 check Queen
D1 and now Queen captures on B2 we have
Rook 8 to G5 and now Queen captures on
B4 with check King to F1 and queen
captures and C4 with check uh Magnus is
now up
um uh two pawns and if there's nothing
for maxim here and he can maybe somehow
get his rook in the game should be very
good for him but it's easier said than
done with King G1 Rook to f8 and now
believe it or not this is what Maxine
played he played Rook captures on F7 and
it doesn't look like something you
should be able to do but uh the pawn on
D6 that got there on move Devin
on move 10 does such a good job here of
preventing the king from going anywhere
that you can actually do this the
problem with capturing is that you just
get a checkmated rook f8 Queen to H5
check King has to move and now of course
you see the pawn uh control sword all of
the squares and this will now be
Checkmate so here you have the guard df3
Square because the real threat is real
characters on a f8 followed by Queen to
F3 so here Queen to E4 Magnus stops
Queen to F3 and now we have Rook G to G7
doubling up and now if you start
checking the black king here it's all
over so your Magnus has to trade here
but now Comes The Rook to G8 check Rook
to f8 and queen to H5 with check again
Magnus has the part with his queen queen
to G6 and now Rook captures with age
captures Queen captures and G6 King to
d8 and now Queen to G5 with check here
Maxim actually got a very good position
because I believe Magnus played this
automatically it's much better to play a
weird move like Rook to F7 uh simply
because the the king is not in a weird
position here the with the pawn covering
C7 and D7 the blacking really doesn't
want to be
on d8 but okay Magnus played this and
now Maxim should really start advancing
his H1 but he played Queen to G5 check
King to C8 and now Queen to C5 with
check King to B7 Queen to B5 check King
to C8 and queen back to C4 Chair King B7
Queen to C7 check King to A6 and queen
captures on D7 so he wins a pawn creates
a pass deep on and uh remember that's
the pawn that got there on move 10 so
that's why Queen to C7 is a much
preferred move to magnus's Bishop to B7
because you just don't allow this Pawn
to survive for this long uh Rook after
d8 chases away the queen queen captures
an E6 and now King the B6 now the
problem with Rook to b60 you might think
well let's just win this pawn it doesn't
really work because after Queen they eat
you check or uh for example Queen day to
check now you have to play King to B5
now we're gonna play Queen to D5 check
nicely centralized and once uh the king
moves you're gonna play this uh Pawn all
the way to D7 and it's a very very
difficult to attack it the problem is um
and now white will start advancing the H
Pawn and if you try to go after the pawn
then Queen to C6 check will pick up the
Rook on B7 and if you defend them Queen
the C8 check will pick up this Rook or
if you trade then you just lose a full
Rock so add that out of the question so
that's why you can't really go Rook to
B6 so King to B6 by Magnus we have Queen
to E7 and now Pawn to A5 now Magnus
starts advancing his past a pawn queen
to C7 checking to B5 and King to F1 we
have quanta A4 and now King the E2 Maxim
says all right my only way my only
chance if I'm ever gonna win this is to
actually bring my king into the game
because pushing my Pawn is just too slow
we have Pawn to A3 King to D3 and now
Rook to A8 but Magnus puts a rook behind
the pass pawn it would be a bit more
precise to First claim the C and the B
file for for the Rooks kick away the
queen as far as possible and then put
the Rook on A8 if it's needed at all but
okay he goes Rook day8 right away King
the D4 and now point the A2 we have
Queen to B7 check King the A4 now
threatening Ponte A1 this will Queen
with check but now Queen to B2 stopping
the queening of the a pawn and here
Magnus to just play A1 Queen he has to
get his King off of the a file and he
should just play A1 whatever piece Queen
Knight Bishop Rook doesn't really matter
and once the queen captures you gets the
safety with King to B5 and next you're
gonna capture the pawn on D6 so that's
the way to a draw uh however Magnus
played Rook captures on D6 with check
and this just blunders the game away
because now Maxine plays King to C5 and
look at the problem here Checkmate is
being threatened and also the Rook is
being threatened and you you can deliver
one check Rook to see it check but then
again uh The Rook comes off and there's
no way to play this for Magnus played
Rook to B6 it's one last attempted it's
tricking Maxim which uh you know you
have three options here you either lose
the game win the game or Draw the game
here if you play uh Queen capture some
B6 then Rook the CH check will allow for
a draw because after the king moves you
will play Rook to C1 and now uh there is
no way um for white to actually win this
another uh really a cool move is at that
after Rook to B6 if you play King
captures then of course Rook to be able
to check will win Maxim's Queen and then
it's Magnus wins the game but Maxim says
I want none of this that's a really
silly move just Queen captures on a2's
Checkmate so this is uh what I'm going
to play as the white king is boxing in
the black king so that's pretty much it
so Magnus one game three but he lost
game four uh as you've seen here so he
had the draw but it seems that at some
point he just liked his position too
much and wanted to play for a win but it
didn't go his way and then in the
Armageddon uh let me just uh I don't
want to trick you guys let me just check
the exact order of moves
uh in the Armageddon of course as you
already know Magnus won the match Magnus
had the black pieces he was able to get
a draw uh after some 54 moves he was
better for the entire game even had some
winning chances but uh in Armageddon he
says oh he said all right I I already
messed up uh in game four I don't wanna
you know uh try and uh grab too much and
then uh lose everything so Magnus wins
he wins the Armageddon he wins the match
and he's the a cup division one a
winners Champion uh until uh you know
until we reached the Grand Final of
course uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely played
by Maxine uh and also now you see uh the
the reason behind why uh why in this
line Queen to C7 is the preferred move
not Bishop to B7 because it simply stops
Knight to D6 with check so there we have
it I would like to thank eBay
numismatics the brooders on Spotify
George de Gregorio Jonathan Johnson and
Robert arathon for a contribution to my
channel thank you lot really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you want a chance at playing all it
is first link in the description below
see you soon